-- ABRUPTLY AND HE FLEW HOME.
BACK IN THIS COUNTRY THE GREEN
NEW DEAL ALMOST OVERNIGHT HAS
TAKEN OVER THE ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENDA IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ SAID WE
NEED TO GROUND OUR PLANES AND
STOP HAVING KIDS FOR THE SAKE OF
THE PLANET AND NEED TO STOP
EATING HAMBURGERS.
ALTHOUGH HER CHIEF OF STAFF WAS
CAUGHT DOWNING ONE FOR DINNER
THE OTHER NIGHT.
IF WE WENT TO WIND AND SOLAR,
WOULD THAT FIX THE PROBLEMS WE
NEED TO FIX?
MICHAEL HAS SPENT MANY YEARS
LOOKING AT THIS AND DOESN'T
THINK SO.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRESS.
YOU WROTE A PIECE THEY THOUGHT
WAS REALLY SMART AND
INTERESTING.
I RECOMMEND IT TO EVERYONE
WATCHING BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL OF
SCIENTIFIC DETAILS IN IT.
IT'S ABOUT WIND AND SOLAR.
THE CLAIM THAT WE COULD SHIFT
THE GRID TO RELY ON WIND AND
SOLAR OVERNIGHT AND BE OKAY.
YOU SAY THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE.
>> YES, I WAS ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF THE ORIGINAL GREEN
BILL IN 2003 TO 2007.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WE SPENT
150-BILLION DOLLARS ON
RENEWABLES AND KEPT ENCOUNTERING
THE SAME PROBLEMS EVERYWHERE
THAT WERE RELATED TO THE
UNRELIABILITY OF SOLAR AND WIND.
DEPENDING ON WHEN THE SUN IS
SHINING AND THE WIND IS BLOWING.
AND THE LOW ENERGY DENSITY OF
SUNLIGHT DOLLAR WIND.
-- AND WIND.
YOU HAVE TO USE A LOT MORE
NATURAL RESOURCES INCLUDING LAND
TO GENERATE VERY MUCH
ELECTRICITY.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT.
THEN YOU POINT TO ANOTHER FORM
OF ENERGY THAT HAS A REPUTATION,
NUCLEAR.
>> YES.
WE WERE IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
THINGS LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE OR
AIR POLLUTION.
WE HAD A NUMBER OF FRIENDS WHO
SAID WHAT ABOUT NUCLEAR?
WE WERE LIKE WELL, NUCLEAR IS
SCARY AND HAVE CONCERNS.
I READ ABOUT ALL OF THE
ACCIDENTS AND WAS SHOCKED HOW
FEW PEOPLE DIED IN CHERNOBYL.
THE MOST RECENT ACCIDENT NOBODY
WILL DIE FROM THE RADIATION.
THAT IS EXPLAINED BY THE ENERGY
DENSITY.
WE FIND THAT BIO-MASS AND
BURNING WIDE AND FOSSILE FUELS
KILL 7 MILLION A YEAR FROM
SMOKE.
THAT SMOKE IS A FUNCTION OF THE
WASTE PRODUCT IN THE AIR AND
PEOPLE BREATHING IT.
WITH NUCLEAR, EVEN IN THE WORST
ACCIDENT, ONLY A TINY AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL CHEAPSKATE.
THE ENERGY DENSITY OF THE FUEL
DETERMINES HOW MUCH AIR
POLLUTION THERE WOULD BE.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE WHO WROTE THE
GREEN NEW DEAL MUST HAVE
CONSULTED SCIENTISTS AND KNOW
WHAT YOU JUST SAID IS TRUE.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> OF.
>> Tucker: WHY ISN'T NUCLEAR
PART OF THE SOLUTION?
>> IT'S DISAPPOINTING.
-- THERE ARE 3 BIG REASONS.
FIRST ASSOCIATED WITH THE BOMB
WHICH IS WRONG.
THEY ARE TWO SEPARATE
TECHNOLOGIES.
IN THE '60s AND TODAY THERE WERE
CONCERN TOO MUCH CHEAP ENERGY
WOULD RESULT IN OVER-POPULATION
AND OVER-CONSUMPTION.
THE THIRD ONE THE MOST POWERFUL
IS A STRONG DESIRE TO USE ENERGY
TO HARMONIZE WITH THE NATURAL
WORLD.
THAT TURNS OUT TO BE A BAD IDEA.
BECAUSE THE MORE MATERIAL
RESOURCES WE USE, THE WORSE IT
IS FOR THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME.